are you sick of all the fees and the
hassle of having a checking account at a
big bank check out our sponsor current
using the link below I'll tell you more
about them at the end of the video the
current administration is going to go
down not just as one of the most
incompetent but as one of the most
uncaring and immoral administration's in
modern American political history and
why am I saying this today I mean I
could really say it on any day but
yesterday Vice President Mike Pence went
to the Mayo Clinic for a staged photo op
and he refused to wear a mask now a mask
aside you could make the argument he
really shouldn't be going at all
traveling from Washington DC to
Minnesota at all especially for someone
like pence who's around a whole bunch of
people all the time going to a place
where people are being treated for
coronavirus and other serious conditions
introducing germs why even do it it's a
bad idea he shouldn't do it at all but
he went he went for the photo-op and he
was told to wear a mask and he did not
as you can see if you're watching today
everybody wearing a mask Secret Service
the patient nurses people in the back
room but Mike Pence not wearing a mask
the Mayo Clinic tweeted quote Mayo
Clinic had informed vice-president of
the masking policy prior to his arrival
today they told him but pence refused to
wear a mask the Mayo Clinic ended up
deleting their tweet about having told
pence about the mask policy about three
hours after they posted it were they
pressured by the administration we don't
know but that tweet was since deleted by
the Mayo Clinic here is Mike Pence
surrounded by people with masks he's the
one guy in the room without one take a
look take a listen
and this started and brought the food to
the FDA in two weeks
so why didn't Mike Pence wear a mask he
was asked and he says because he is
regularly tested for the virus and he
wants to look people in the eye take a
look decision not wear a mask on the
Mayo Clinic is the governor and other
officials here did can you just walk us
through why he's made a decision well
let me say as vice president in the
United States I'm tested for the corona
virus on a regular basis and everyone
who is around me is tested for the
corona virus and when the CDC issued
guidelines about wearing a mask it was
their recognition that people that may
have the corona virus could prevent the
possibility of conveying the virus to
someone else by wearing a mask and since
I don't have the corona virus I I
thought it'd be a good opportunity for
me to be here meant to be able to speak
to these researchers these incredible
health care personnel and look them in
the eye and and say thank you he wanted
to look people in the eye to say thank
you does Mike Pence know that you don't
cover your face I'm sorry that you don't
cover your eyes with the mask you're
only covering your nose and mouth
someone someone tweeted me about this he
said you know David maybe Mike Pence is
used to a type of white face mask that
does cover your entire face if you guys
know what I mean that's a joke by the
way
I think as far as I know anyway so this
is one of the dumbest explanations and
this includes the testing thing now Mike
Pence says he's tested regularly and
people around him are tested regularly
you could be incubating the disease it's
possible you could be contagious before
a test result would come back positive
we just don't know and of course Pence
is flying around he's the last person
who should be going to a hospital
without wearing a mask if Mike Pence
brought an asymptomatic or
pre-symptomatic early case of corona
virus to the Mayo Clinic
do you realize the amount of havoc that
he could personally wreak it is
infuriating and it is toxically
irresponsible but they don't care now
what do I think the real reason is why
Mike Pence didn't wear a mask they
managed by optics okay they want to
pretend that we're on the other side of
this pandemic they want to pretend like
hey listen we're States are opening
everything's good we're about to win if
a vice president who has not been seen
wearing a mask for months during the
pandemic all of a sudden on April 28th
for the first time wears a mask in
public the optics are not that we've
almost won now of course we've not
almost won it would be accurate to
realize that we've not almost won but
its management by optics and pence
doesn't want to be seen wearing a mask
what I would like to have seen is the
Mayo Clinic simply deny Mike Pence entry
now I know it's the vice president I
know he flew there from Washington DC
these things are carefully choreographed
like a dance it would have been a very
bold move for the Mayo Clinic to do that
but I find it more bold and certainly
more disrespectful and disgusting for
pence to go in there without a mask you
have people who have family members at
the Mayo Clinic with coronavirus family
members and they're not allowed to go
visit at all never mind with a mask
because the risk is too great and Mike
Pence flies in from DC and is walking
around with no mask I hope that when
this is all over what and by that I mean
the virus and this administration and
hopefully that's sooner than later on
both counts I hope we don't forget how
incompetent this administration is but I
also hope we don't forget how
disrespectful and flat-out terrible
people this administration has been made
up of because it is absolutely and
completely disgusting we'll have more
coverage of this on our Instagram page
at david pakman show also follow me on
instagram at david pakman if you're
looking for a break from bad news every
day follow my urban gardening experience
which I am
reporting on consistently on my
Instagram page at David Pakman we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this we often talk about the many
different ways that big banks take
advantage of their customers and one of
our sponsors today is current which is
an online bank for those of us who are
sick of dealing with all of the fees and
the nonsense from the big banks I use
current myself if you're watching this
on YouTube here's my actual current
debit card that I'm holding up no
minimum balance they have 24/7 support
no overdraft fees up to $100 and it
won't get declined no ATM fees you can
use over fifty five thousand ATMs
nationwide and unlike other banks you
receive your direct deposits instantly
which means you'll get paid by your
employer up to two days sooner you can
deposit checks instantly using your
camera phone and unlike other banks
current instantly refunds the hold on
your card from pumping gas you can pause
your debit card instantly also really
useful in many situations there are just
so many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes
two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video